vous êtes mon invité on va on va pas
faire le serpent de suite pour vous vous
allez faire le danseur de zhouqu
d'accord vous allez devoir épeler des
mots en dansant le zouk mais un zouk
effréné voilà notre ami qui est avec
nous à l'osu coeur le carnassier
atterrir et avait carrément quel est
votre prénom cathy attention je vous
donnais un premier mon attention c'est
parti
il faut que vous mais pas les deux
shérifs cars irakienne girard à lorca
cohen oui j
non j ai assez non non non pas il manque
un mot il manquait n'y est fait danser
la gigue y qu'elle jjj génie djg hier à
ses très bons la télé c'est bon la jouer
et non comme md
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]